hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu fifa 13
noch road to glory wir schon
wahrscheinlich seht oben rechts an
meinen statistiken bzw einmal in münzen
und fifa points ich habe ein bisschen
gezockt wir haben großes problem gemacht
ich hatte ja noch 1500 fifa polster so
beim letzten aufnahmen oder 2000 den
drehen wir alles ausgegeben die besten
spieler die ich hatte war neuer für 80
km und theo walcott und der kostet auch
nicht mehr als 10 k ein bisschen weniger
sogar noch die sache ist einfach die wir
haben nur bullshit gezogen und das hat
sich nicht gelohnt ich habe ja dann
direkt wieder verkauft und habe dazu
noch mein ganzes deutsches team verkauft
einschließlich özil etc und hat mein
englisches team jetzt quasi behalten
damit so ein englisches eventuell werde
ich bald nochmal ein spanisches machen
euch bleibt erstmal beim englischen weil
mit denen läuft eigentlich ganz gut also
ich hab bisher zwei spiele einer saison
okay ein sieg eine niederlage aber die
niederlage war einfach so weil ich
einfach keine chance nutzt ist einfach
so ich hab keine ahnung
ganz einfach keine chance und ich dachte
jetzt mal wieder rote glaube hier können
wir doch eigentlich mal wieder hier so
ein pech öffnen und hoffen dass da etwas
gutes drin ist carrick michael carrick
habe ich schon in meiner englischen
mannschaft von daher bringt da nicht
viel das ist nämlich ein duplikat land
so die soll nicht so gut ich verstehe
ich was soll ich mit solchen leuten den
vertrag immer klarer welche für die
modifikation 5323 auch nicht-spieler
training
objekt listen allgemein liste ich nun
immer spielen ist das letztens schon mal
passiert dass ich ein spieler gelistet
habe und der kostete nach her dass ich
ein spieler sofort verkauft hat für 300
kostete nachher 4000 hat noch einer die
kommentare geschrieben daher liste ich
jetzt einfach mal alle wenn sie danach
nicht weggehen dann mache ich sofort
verkaufen
wieviel michael carrick wert ist weiß
ich auch nicht und ich behalte ihn jetzt
auch einfach nicht wenn ich hab den eh
schon meiner mannschaft das einzige was
er gut kann es passen oder ich
eigentlich auch finde das den ganz guten
schuss hatte den spielervertrag verwende
ich einfach mal sofort bei turu oder
wieder heißt ihr müsst wissen ich habe
ungefähr 40 gold verträge einfach nur
dass es so krass
das ist richtig übel oder zuvor
angeschlagen übrigens stellt euch darauf
ein dass die nächsten tage
beziehungsweise wochen erst wenn nicht
so viel fifa kommt weil ich jetzt eine
menge klausuren schreiben wieder
klausurphase hier ich hoffe mal das
schaffe ich ungefähr ohne defizit und ja
drückt mir da einfach die daumen auch
net all for excel brauche jetzt sofort
wieder im vertrag
drückt man am besten die daumen die
nächsten wochen einfach mal komplett
jeden tag daumen drücken für mich damit
ich das dann irgendwie der gebacken
kriege ich schaue ganz gestoppt die
halle flitzen
das sieht gar nicht gut aus was ist denn
mit kostenlos das sieht gar nicht gut
aus so der real kam wieder spielen die
gwg abwehr packen wir sind zwar ein
braun ist er denn schnell der ist nicht
schnell wird man braucht einfach
schneller verteidiger der medica
herkommen rafael ist der film gut das
spiel ist bei mir
wir machen das so gut endspiel der zu
recht seit 780 okay das passt schon
der muss auch damit irgendwie raus das
heißt wir können sich danach einfach ein
zentrales mittelfeld western paulinho na
gut
zentrale offensive mittelfeld ins
mittelfeld links außen habe ich
irgendwie in der linkes mittelfeld ist
und was hat er hier so für werte 90er
tempo alter
sondern krieg so einen typen pflicht
zumal gestern schnell die reihe der
letztes spiel schon gespielt ich kann
einfach storage reinbringen oh gott
jetzt passt ja auch nicht für dann nehme
ich dir nämlich dahin und dann kein wort
auch nicht spielen
walker tempo 96 ergebnis dass man es
noch mal richtig krass recht
verteidigung zentrale innenverteidiger
ich will hier raus einstellen du spielst
jetzt einfach mal die riders der war
ganz gut im sturm eigentlich auch nicht
spielen lassen
ich mag einfach mal den kaffee dann kann
er einfach hierfür spielen so ist jetzt
zwar eine b-elf aber ich hoffe mal dass
wir dass da irgendwie mit schaffen
welcher grad mit der a-elf gespielt habe
gewonnen
dafür habe ich wieder mit der b elf
gespielten da hab ich dann verloren so
ruht hier komm mach jetzt hier los
326 gegner suche gegner den den linden
den bindenden
wir sind die schon 55 minuten am
aufnehmen und was kommt bisher gar kein
gegner
niemand kann sagen wie ich super an der
tria metric ok läuft wetten dass ist die
dass in übelster pro wenn man real
madrid eben was davon guckt was sage ich
wenn irgendwas von real madrid hat ist
man automatisch gut dass er hat ein
komplett englisches team sein torwart
kenne ich zwar nicht aber ein 80 kirchen
nicht spiels holländer keine ahnung ich
denke das werden wir höchstgradig
verpacken
da könnte ich mit euch wetten vor allem
weil ich so weit vom fernsehgerät das
demnächst mal so machen immer welt
aufnehmen nämlich dann direkt zehn
folgen hintereinander auf und dann
stellte er das mikro einfach mal direkt
vom fernseher zeichne ich muss mich auch
schon so komisch wir alles umsetzen muss
ich habe den fernseher auf meinem
schreibtisch den nutzer wissen
und komischerweise auch immer wenn ich
so spiele reagiert das ding voll spät
alter wenn der eingegangenen er jungen
ich jetzt so gefeiert aus der position
also irgendwie reagiert das ganze mit
der elgato bei mir ein bisschen später
ich werde mir wahrscheinlich demnächst
irgendwann mal neuen pc zusammenstellen
bzw
meinen eltern das irgendwie so sagen ja
mein pc jetzt total kacke
er ist ja auch khaki mandy das einzige
was gut ist ist der grafikspeicher und
der prozessor aber die grafikkarte
ich habe nie eine schlechtere grafik
karte gesehen
wenn ich battlefield in hd spielen will
einfach nur ich wollte es ja eigentlich
auch mal hochladen
das geht einfach nicht mal weil das dann
das dankamt battlefield bei mir ab was
sie eigentlich für den verspielten der
ich verstehe dass der welt der sterne
auslinie dribbelte ein bisschen fühlt
sich toll an ich auch was geht so wenn
ihr bringt das allerdings was übrigens
ich habe bei facebook gefragt ob ihr ob
ich so wenig flug oder soll ich das
rausschneiden soll oder ob ich das drin
lassen soll beziehungsweise als ob ihr
dass er gut findet er ja schlecht findet
und da kam bei rum dass ich das doch
drin lassen sollte um das menschliche
kopf er kam herum dass das dort drin
lassen sollte beziehungsweise habe ich
dazu gefragt und alle waren wirklich
dafür hin in den kommentaren gefährlich
bei facebook
es kann nicht wahr sein
meine herrn jetzt seine ohne witz ja
egal welches spiel auf nämlich nicht
einfach nur auf die fresse ich hab's
auch bei facebook gefragt ob ich
eventuell das so machen durfte aber ich
gefragt ob ich das darf dass ich sage
ich mal
die spieler aufnehmen und dann nachher
kommentiere die spiele die ganz gut
waren sage ich mal
das heißt nicht mehr alles leid weil ich
kann einfach nicht gut spielen wenn ich
hier am quatschen bin um mein gott das
war ein gutes tue das und ich feiere den
jubel so übel wie hast du killer sein
reiter naja ok ich kann einfach nicht
gut spiele aussetzen dass es war ein
ganz guter andere besser halten sonntag
schoss aber ich kann nicht gut spielen
wenn ich wenn ich dabei quatschen muss
einfach also schreibt es mir doch bitte
mal die kommentare an alle die jetzt
noch dabei sind viele klicken das video
angeklickt sofort wieder weg sich an den
statistiken von google analytics und
mein gott ich liebe das wenn so ein typ
denkt zuhört trick sich dann über den
ball ab und schießen nächsten angriff
dann das tor
moskau
das war geil gemacht oder das war geil
gemacht china sagte er dem ndr
gibbs den gibt's die gibt's also ob ich
dann lieber dort nach kommentieren soll
oder so also dann kann ich auch ein
bisschen dass sie die fahrzeuge sechs
minuten lang jetzt sagt er nicht gar so
macht man 20 minuten das dann noch viel
cooler
naja ich glaube eher dass fünf minuten
komprimiert mit den highlights besser
sind als 20 minuten nur bullshit hier
wenn man allein schon ein paar minuten
da warten muss bis der gegner überhaupt
drin ist heute die nicht abgeblockt ich
werde dabei auch seine ecke torwart ohne
witz ich wusste warum ich ihn nicht
kenne
der kann nix niederländische tod hat die
können nichts aus schale geile lässt ihr
den staaten oder starten welches alter
werden nicht das letzte in die aufpassen
dass wir den den konnte ich ihn mir
kriegt also ich würde das dann quasi so
machen wie das sportschau wenn die
besten szenen rausschneiden bisschen
drumrum labern und so dass ich denke ihr
wisst da ungefähr wie ich mir das
vorstelle
schöner pass super gemacht
nein erklärt er den darauf und dann
kommt er doch noch dran
denn hierfür glück chancen da der ok war
mädels haben wir den haben jetzt vorbei
man n trägt nicht gemerkt schade ich
muss echt sagen die nato reagiert bei
mir ein bisschen später wenn dieser
tipps bitte einfach in die kommentare
wer sehr netz scheiße geil dass wir
darauf vernahm auf jeden fall habe ich
gezogen was geht
nein hey guck das ist es nämlich wieder
ich habe den trick schon längst
ausgeführt und dem spiel kommt einfach
so derbe später weil das hier so
behindert später als reagiert auf der
elgato ich muss quasi jeden zug sag ich
mal fünf sekunden früher machen
na gut ich bin hier um zu meckern das
mache ich wenn ich zurückblicke
okay wir müssen jetzt auf jeden fall
erstmal noch nachlegen
ich weiß dass ich aus der defensive auf
die offensive
wir müssen auf jeden fall noch ein tor
nachlegen weil sonst wird das nichts mit
dem sieg
das weiß jetzt schon auch du scheiße ist
vor dem spiel solche sicherungen hier
haben wieso kriegt denn bitte alle bälle
verdammt ist hat er mich wie demütig
borger kommt er nicht ran okay gut
scheiße was geht das mal nicht so jetzt
tricks darum mit ass bringt ihm okay es
mir vorbeigekommen
aber es hat ihn im endeffekt nichts
gebracht
ich meine hätte auch einfach so dran
vorbei gehen können das ist einfach es
sind sachen die die verstehe eh scheiße
alter was macht mein keeper dafür geile
sachen bei dessen schiller
dann machen wir halt mal los alex oxlade
chamberlain vor gott was bitte ist den
schuss gewesen
alt-kanzler gleichfalls als abstoß keine
ahnung dings benennen scheiße den wir
euch nicht passt der komplett so schön
nach außen bislang komplett mein gott
superschuss muss ich sagen von pauline
den habe reingemacht wusste ich nicht
dass ich ihn habe
aber das ist ein gutes und freizeit ich
den mal angenommen online verdammten
bamba
oder wird es echt so dass ich ihn
meistens ein ok ok schade das ist das
einzige was ich hier sage dem display
und irgendwie sowas wie super gemacht
und das war zum beispiel schnell werde
ich auch bald mal so in seine fifa
onetouch machen wenn ich in winterferien
dazu zeit finde dass ich so die besten
sachen einfach mal raus schneidet die
größten fans sage ich mal
jetzt stelle sich dann wieder hin
trickst ein bisschen und läuft im grunde
genommen wieder hierhin und diesmal ich
habe mich von mitbekommen diesmal wollte
ich mir den ball wenn ich mal drauf
kommen würde
danke und jetzt halbzeit
genau im angriff ich kann euch zehn
millionen sachen aufzählen wo ich bin
nachteilig werde weil ich trainer von
bildschirmen um
ich hab das mikrofon gehabt das gehört
wenn ihr jetzt sind zuschauer sah ihr
wissen was die fifa kraft ihre sitze
sind echt und normal und und ich meine
das spiel mit aufs ergebnis ins tor
holen jedoch mein gott dieses dass sie
nicht faul wenn einer gegen läuft es
kann zwar nichts für aber beim fest dass
er oft so dass falls geführt werden auch
wenn briggs dafür kommen kann
super gemacht von der abwehr hier auch
das klasse gemacht
nein wieso kommt ein pass aus fünf
metern nicht an halo alter wat soll dat
fünf meter pass kommt nicht an
richtig wäre dann zugleich wenigstens
ihr den ball zurück leute junge jetzt
hause sich gegenseitig im alltag ohne
witze was ist das hier
ich frag mich echt ist das den affen
fein oder das ist eine fußballmannschaft
ok wahrscheinlich könnte doch fußball
spielen so ein bisschen raus rücken ein
verdammt das wollte ich vermeiden kann
lernen auf storage schön gemacht vorteil
haben wir wenig leute vorne
das heißt wir können ein geschlecht
nachlegen das heißt wir sind ja
eigentlich jetzt noch am mauern setzt
sich die man hier auf ausgeglichen und
ganz frei sagt alter wieso geben der
dann nicht vorher schon an walter ist
kann doch nicht sein so ein taktischer
fehler und ich nutze das nicht aus er
das kann es nicht sein
scheiße mann na gut okay ich hoffe wir
werden jetzt nicht dafür bestraft und
ich glaube das werden wird weil jetzt
mit richtig richtig vielen leuten vor
mir
okay dann haben wir den haben den hammer
los mädels am ball ist klasse
super gemacht lieber die gerd wirklich
mit der beste mann hier das kommt er
wieder mit seiner showeinlage super hat
ihm richtig viel gebracht jetzt scheiße
achtung jetzt kommt ja ok
stecken muss auch wieder denn eine
extrawurst bekommen
aber so wirklich was was aufs tor
bringen schafft es nicht das gewissen
des tollen start okay wenn er wechseln
will dann wechseln wir auch mal den köln
werden da so rein bringen
rechtes mittelfeld habe ich hier ein
linkes mittelfeld und zentrales
mittelfeld rechten verteidiger ryan und
immer das mal kurz ein bisschen familien
rechten verteidiger heißt wir stellen
die formation auf 433 kann man irgendwie
42 das doch gut 45 14 stürmer im spiel
aber okay okay kriegt sogar noch kommen
wenn jetzt das tor macht als die
perfekte mit auf die musiker gestellt
haben ok haben sie nicht nein wenn er
letzten sommer ist natürlich sehr sehr
ärgerlich klasse klasse klasse super
gemacht klasse passt alter baum ist so
ein körpereinsatz bitte kein elfmeter
ich weiß der typisch mächtig aber wenn
man dann so reingeht im körper dann kann
man das schon mal elfmeter pfeifen die
schiene
warum passen
meine spieler sind alle so müde das
richtig sein kann wie beim tor und ich
nutze es wieder nicht aus alter meine
chance verwertung ist unter aller sau
mit diesem komischen elgato tings hier
ja klar was ein zufall war schön
herausgespielt muss ich sagen
klasse muss sagen dass ich echt glück so
der beste mann vollkommen ein bisschen
tempo
was ist das denn bitte
ich habe nicht mehr passen gedrückt
junge wie behindert ist was soll das ich
drücke nicht mehr passen besser und er
passt einfach und ich glaube zu unserer
scheiße zu unserer auswechslung von
vorhin kommt auch nicht mehr
der bei der rallye wm aus ok kommen
jetzt setzt sie durch die durchaus
historisch aber nicht du bist auch nicht
draußen glaube ich ich dachte schon
jetzt extra nicht gewartet damit jetzt
noch hier in so ein bisschen das zu ende
spielen können mit gleichen and end and
end endphase sage ich mal
die leute kommen dich rein bringen
wollte jetzt denken wir natürlich
perfekt unternimmt der mörder den ball
ab da hinten nicht sein
scheiße
gut klasse gemacht bekommen jetzt laufe
im auslauf nein nein ok schade war ein
guter versuch herr keine ahnung wer das
war
das war zum beispiel schlecht von ihm
gemacht weil er hätte aufs tor laufen
können und dann einfach abspielen können
so sweater like aber hat er nicht
gemacht bin ich ihm sehr dankbar gut
jetzt sind die leute rein gekommen
seit wir sind schon ein bisschen fitter
hinten der pass kommt an
pauli ist aber auch schon so ein
bisschen müde kann mir auch vorstellen
dass er gleich einfach mal so
zusammenbricht nein eigentlich ist doch
wenn man dreimal auf druck ist doch so
flache dings eine flache flanke oder
weil das hab ich halt gemacht oder kann
zudem sowohl komisch dass ich das jetzt
einfach zu ende spielen ich glaube ich
mache das jetzt gut verlaufen jetzt
einfach nach draußen stellen uns jetzt
mal eine runde hin laufen dann wieder
zurück und dann ist halbzeit also vorbei
nein nein verdammt scheiße ja gut zu
ende gespielt klasse gemacht wo sie
sagen super von meinem team super dass
er das noch hier kriegt damit der b11
betone ich noch mal und ich schon dass
ich das mit dem englischen zunächst
auszahlt die strippen ziehen
und ja ich würde sagen das schreit
danach dass wir bald wieder ein großes
pack opening machen
meine damen und herren und lob gut ich
würde sagen das weiß ich mal für diese
folge schaffen wir 200 daumen hoch
775 hat bei ultimate team einen gold
geöffnet schön ich habe mir zwei daumen
hoch für diese folge dass wir echt krass
geil schreiben die kommentare ob ich
nicht eventuell doch nach kommentieren
soll oder wir das haben wollte und dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal